all right so we're going to kind of
close our coverage of this wacky weekend
in alaska we looked at the trump rally
we looked at sarah palin we're now going
to look at some interviews with rally
attendees and one of the things we
realized was that trump supporters in
alaska are just as delusional and just
as disconnected from reality as those in
other parts of the country alaska often
gets this reputation sort of like
vermont of being a different type of
place where left and right don't mean
the same things and the republicans are
more reasonable and the liberals are
more conservative you know all these
different things because of its rural
and all these stuff maybe to some degree
that that's true and in fact i think it
is true to some degree but no shortage
of whacked out delusional
uh participants i guess in the political
system
here some women are asked what are the
main issues that are of concern to you
the main political issues women in
alaska what are you worried about
um i'm not going to preview what they
say let's listen to what they say
what's the most important issue that you
guys are concerned about as alaska oh
space force all right qr keeling
the support of our veterans the healing
i'm sorry trafficking specifically what
kind of trafficking uh human trafficking
are you worried about our southern
border
yes everything
i think eventually they'll end up going
back to their own countries with nasara
jasar kicking in
right now
there's a lot there
so
the main issues for women in alaska
conservative women principled
conservative women are
space force uh which is doing nothing
right now
qr codes killing people i think is what
she said
veterans okay veterans healing
healing's great but from what and in
what way
trafficking
and the southern border of the united
states which is quite removed both
geographically and politically from
what's happening in alaska alaska of
course sharing a border with canada
these are the issues that they say are
the most important now at the end you
might have heard that this woman
mentions nasara and jasara going back to
their own countries with nasara jasar
kicking in okay when that i watched that
uh on saturday during our stream
i didn't know what on earth this woman
was talking about
nasara is an acronym for the national
economic security and recovery act
these were some proposed economic
reforms suggested during the 1990s
by a guy named harvey francis barnard
who wanted to replace the income tax
with the national sales tax and get rid
of compound interest on secured loans
and
go back to a
currency backed by two types of precious
metals all these different things and
it's kind of become a cult-like thing
and uh the idea that people are going to
go back to mexico because of nassar i
mean it is so out there that even many
conspiracy theorists have no idea what
it's about so that's what women in
alaska say they care about here's a guy
who is sort of a medical marvel
listen to this guy's voice he seems to
have something in his throat not it not
his not his uh mouth not his nose but
his throat
i've never heard someone speak like this
in an extended way i asked some doctor
friends of mine what exactly is going on
here they said they don't know this
what you're about to hear is defying the
medical knowledge of multiple doctors
check this out look what he did for us i
mean come on man
he's a he's a businessman
he's throwing people up
i i can't even pretend to speak that way
they can't they don't know where they're
at because he
knows ins and outs of business
he got all of our prices down our taxes
down our gas down our food down
demands a dream now not only did trump
not do any of those things i tried uh
holding water in my mouth to try to
sound like that
i tried sort of like speaking through a
gargle i could not replicate that
and what a wild wild day in anchorage
alaska so the supporters also
um
crediting trump with things he didn't do
imagining new conspiracy i mean it's
just completely all over the place
and we have to remember
some of these people vote not all of
them some of them show up at these
rallies they travel all over going to
rallies and they they say they're
devoted to trump they're like no i was
working that day or i wasn't working i
was just doing nothing and i didn't go
and vote
this group of folks
will determine
who controls the house and senate uh
after january of 2023 based on how they
vote this november so
wild
but not to be ignored as a political
constituency
many of us know what it's like to have
acne show up when we least want it to
you should have seen me in middle school
now i'm on camera and i really do the
best i can to keep my skin clear and for
that i go to apostrophe our sponsor on
the apostrophe website you just answer a
few questions take a couple pictures of
your skin and then you have a virtual
visit with a board certified
dermatologist who will create a
personalized treatment plan they quickly
ship you the prescription medication i
can tell you that when it comes to acne
you're better off with a dermatologist
there are all sorts of different kinds
of acne that need different types of
treatment the over-the-counter stuff was
not what worked for me
apostrophe makes it simple and quick
i've had a great experience with
apostrophe myself you get affordable
quality medical treatment from a
licensed dermatologist and prescription
meds that actually work but i can do it
all on my phone i don't have to spend
hours in a doctor's office
my audience gets 15 off your first
dermatology visit go to
dot com slash pacman and use the code
pacman the link is in the description